Ceri what's one trillion dollars to the
tenth power
one tweeting lights to the tenth power
is 1 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0
[Music]
ello Internet welcome to film theory the
show that's skeptical you never get to
infinity let alone beyond so the teasers
and trailers have been Unleashed and Toy
Story 4 looks to be yet another
family-friendly box-office slam-dunk of
a sequel surprising literally no one
least of all the big Mouse himself but
here's the thing about boys story
friends in this day and age of brand
safety and child-friendly programming
where Disney is so squeaky clean and
more than eager to sweep some of their
more questionable decisions under the
rug I am here to tell you that Toy Story
may just be the worst movie of the bunch
and obviously I am no stranger to how
dark Disney movies can get whether it's
cannibalism aboard the good ship axiom
the body count of Moana or Dumbo's
high-flying adventures with an emphasis
on high no childhood memory is safe from
the show but up until now I've decided
to let Toy Story just kind of skate past
my radar I was more than happy to leave
it as the beautiful moving trilogy
commenting on the realities of growing
up that it was but then you mouse and
push your luck he had to go in for yet
another sweet sweet taste of that
money-making nectar
and in the process you summoned my wrath
now I'm here today to prove to the world
that Toy Story is undeniably the sickest
most twisted darkest g-rated movie you
could imagine that these tales of toys
just trying to make their humans happy
is instead a dark picture of inescapable
slavery headed towards eventual disaster
today's episode loyal theorists is dark
we are talking incinerating every
character you love enough furnace levels
of dark that's right folks we're talking
pics are dark and I'm not even hyping
this up for dramatic effect it is a
literal statement of what we are
covering today don't believe me well
let's begin shattering some childhood
shall we just in case you've been locked
in a toy chest since the mid 90s here's
a rundown of the aptly named Toy Story
films which appropriately enough tell
the story of some toys these toys seemed
normal enough when humans are around but
when left alone they come to life the
toys love their owner Andy and they go
to extraordinary lengths to be with him
the original Toy Story film is all about
the arrival of Buzz Lightyear a cool new
toy who threatens to unseat woody is
Andy's favorite they eventually team up
against the kid next door a promising
young man who seems destined to become a
neurosurgeon one day and they scar him
so severely that he goes on to become a
garbage man instead of pursuing his
medical dreams note the skull shirt
there people that is Pixar shorthand for
same person in Toy Story - woody learns
that he's a collector's item and has to
choose between that hashtag museum life
and returning to his kid in Toy Story 3
woody has to choose between that hashtag
daycare life and you guessed it
returning to his kid and in Toy Story
for his trailer woody faces his biggest
choice yet will he choose that hashtag
carnival life or will he return to his
kid so that Pixar can continue printing
money with these sequels to infinity and
beyond I think we all know the answer to
that one now with all that context out
of the way let's hop into the theorizing
shall we imagine for a moment that
you're a toy in Toy Story start with you
coming to life now at this point you've
probably already assumed that a child's
imagination is what indeed
is a toy life but in case there was any
doubt about it the Toy Story 4 trailer
officially makes it canon bonnie made a
friend in class
no no she literally made a new friend
kids are essentially the gods that
giveth life in the Toy Story verse and
from that moment on you're told that
your life has a singular purpose to
bring joy to the humans
and that's not an exaggeration it is a
rule of this universe again represented
by the Toy Story 4 trailer so a child's
imagination gives a toy life which is
cool and all but the weird thing is toys
don't automatically know this when
they're actually given life you are a
child you are a sad strange little man
if you're a toy who's skeptical about
this or doesn't believe it initially
don't worry the concept is gonna get
drilled into your head over and over
until you finally decide to come around
somewhere in that pad of stuffing is a
toy who taught me that life's only worth
living if you're being loved by a kid
and you see that's where our problems
begin not all toys aspire to be a
child's plaything remember how buzz went
through a huge existential crisis when
he found out that he wasn't a Space
Ranger in Toy Story 1 he was devastated
to learn that he wasn't unique that the
identity he thought he had for himself
was a complete fabrication what really
got me thinking about this though was
the Toy Story 4 trailer again where we
meet for KI who's going through an
existential crisis of his own I am NOT a
toy I was taped to soup salad maybe
chili and then the trash
but don't worry about toys like buzz by
the end of the movie he comes around he
learns that toys do in fact have worth
worth that is entirely dependent on
being subservient to the whims of their
masters I mean children kids who really
appreciate the sacrifices that the toys
are making on a day to day basis oh my
kid these masters don't even realize
they're alive the toys are born into a
system where the very fact that they are
alive is kept in the closet both
figuratively and literally a world in
which they are terrified of humans
seeing them as they really are think
about it toys are literally imprisoned
in boxes and bedrooms until a human
child decides it's time to play with
them and you can't see it because this
is all voiceover but I am tossing strong
finger quotes over the word play there
because this so-called playtime is a
hundred percent free of toy consent
whatever that child wants that toy must
oblige you consider all those poor
disrespected Barbies and it's not like
they can't be alive in the presence of
humans it's that they won't they're too
scared to be when the chips are down
sure they'll reveal themselves to humans
if they have to so play nice but the
norm is just to lay there and let your
human do whatever it wants with you and
then cast you aside when they're done
and despite it all the toys still show
unconditional love to their kids
something we all get sniffily over in
the theater because Randy Newman is
singing about friendship or whatever but
if you start peeling back the surface
layers that shot of Jesse looking
longingly out of a window is really just
a textbook case of Stockholm Syndrome
when you look at what the toys go
through and what they have to do to
maintain the status quo of this society
it's a system that outright denies toys
self-determination then doesn't even
allow them to make their own existence
known but humans are the ones who gave
them life in the first place so it makes
sense I hear you saying down in the
comments and sure you are more than
welcome to believe that that is totally
fine with me but before you make your
decision let me also ask you this you
didn't get a choice in being born did
you and so you would also be okay being
the play
thing of your parents you know the
people who gave you life without your
knowledge just asking so as a toy that's
your life a lifetime spent in servitude
to masters who control your every action
and don't even know that you're alive
then as we see in Toy Story 3 they grow
up and they abandon you
yay happy g-rated kids movie but we're
still not done because we haven't taken
this to its logical conclusions because
for as awful as this systemic indentured
servitude might seem at least you have
the sweet release of death to look
forward to right right maybe that's cuz
there are some pretty old toys running
around in these movies in Toy Story 2 we
learned that stinky Pete was
manufactured back in the 50s and he has
an aged one bit since his Woody's
roundup days granted he's done an
exceptional job of keeping himself in
mint condition but the Toy Story 4
trailer features a slew of other vintage
toys they're not under glass and they
seem to be doing just fine too
furthermore toys don't have organs so
riddle me this how are you gonna die of
natural causes if there are no organs
that can fail and further furthermore if
there are no organs inside of a toy no
brain no heart is it even possible to
kill a toy no but really how do toys end
their life in this series think about it
we know for a fact there is nothing in a
toys body or head that is vital to life
after all there's a friggin fishing pole
with legs walking around in SIDS room it
seems to be doing just fine
and thanks to sit again we also know a
toys body part can still function even
after being severed from the body itself
his toys have all been Frankensteined
and swapped around like crazy and
they're all walking around still being
toys really unhappy miserable toys but
still unfortunately for them they're
very much alive and still suffering at
the hands of his torture we also know
that toy death isn't tied to the kids
while it seems perfectly logical that
children as the gods in this world who
giveth life would also taketh it away
when they stop playing make-believe that
isn't the case at all we've seen many
many toys throughout the series who
remain alive long after their children
about grow numb and quit playing
make-believe it's also implied that even
adult toy collectors who just buy toys
and keep them in a box on a shelf can
also instill life into the toys so
throughout
this entire franchise we have yet to see
a truly dead toy of course we've seen
toys die I hear you saying there's the
whole incinerator scene at the end of
toys three and first we've never
actually see if a toys life is truly
taken away by that but secondly what if
it is are you telling me that the only
way that a toy can die is by burning to
death or being completely destroyed I
think again back to SIDS room where toys
are ripped apart armyman are drowned and
maimed in the backyard and they're still
just walking around they need to be
atomized melted into nothing to bite the
big one is that revelation supposed to
make me feel better about this universe
but oh no friends I can tell you one
step further here not only is a death by
fire or explosion or just complete
annihilation the only way for a toy to
bite the big one more often than not
it's also gonna have to require them to
make the choice themselves most toys are
gonna have to choose to finish
themselves off I mean think about it
if I throw my woody away and it goes to
the garbage dump from there he's still
alive he's either buried alive under the
mounds of garbage that Wally's gonna
collect in a few centuries or else
wandering around the wasteland alongside
the fragments of all the other broken
abandoned toys unless they actively seek
out an incinerator they're just there
hanging out forever
yearning for a death that will never
come until they make the choice to
sacrifice themselves to the fire sure
it's one of the most moving tense
emotional scenes ever watching our
heroic toys escape the incinerator at
the end of Toy Story 3 but the sad truth
is that that slow descent into the fire
is what awaits most of the toys that we
see throughout these movies oh wait
sorry they have to go through the
chopper first so there you have it
ladies and gentlemen think about that as
you line up to go see Toy Story 4 which
will undoubtedly be about woody growing
up and finding a new purpose in life
finding a life path that doesn't depend
on making children happy because he just
like Bo Peep and those creepy
ventriloquist dolls is just too old for
children to love anymore it's probably
got asbestos and a stuffing or something
like that and what else is what are you
gonna do
he's never gonna die at least until the
moment he chooses to or randomly catches
on fire Disney brand safe for all the
kiddies so that my friends is the dark
truth of
boys story the one that they don't want
you thinking about too much as they play
that Randy Newman song for the umpteenth
time show us the garbage dumps Disney I
want the receipts reveal the truth to us
but then again there is one other way
this whole Toy Story could play out if
you look at the toys across the three
movies the Pixar universe could be
headed into a state of war a human vers
toy total war and if that's the case
well it's not gonna be looking too good
for the humans but more on that in the
next episode in the meantime remember
what woody always says
wait what that's not what you say woody
also it sounds horrific Lee painful no
actually no one ever has but uh let me
guess because you're a member of Dollar
Shave Club Wow who knew that this
beloved animated character would also
support our sponsor for today's episode
Dollar Shave Club now by this point
you're probably just like old woody here
you're familiar with the old DSC
delivering top-quality shaving products
to your door at your own personal pace
you find that incredibly heavy-duty
executive razor in a box on your
doorstep rather than your boot woody but
what you may not be as familiar with are
all the other amazing hygiene products
that they offer from tooth care to skin
care to but care and even though they're
named for their shade of everything that
they offer I gotta say their shampoos
and conditioners are actually my
favorite they smell amazing and they
give my scalp that cleans so fresh it
makes your head table you know that
feeling right it is the best which is
why I'm so excited about their new
Hawaiian ginger face cleanser as a guy
I've never been a big fan of washing my
face with soaps and lotions and all that
it's gross I know but heck that was just
me
how dirty is my face getting on a
day-to-day basis really but now that I'm
older and trying the sample I finally
get it
it feels great it smells great next it
really keeps my complexion staying clear
and if you're interested in trying it
and being convinced just like I was you
can do it now for just five dollars
which will get you there shave starter
set the
to end all razors the executive a
cassette with four additional razor
refills a tube of their classic shaving
butter and the chance to sample that new
Hawaiian face cleanser there's all of
that for five bucks that is less than
the cost of a fancy cup of coffee and
you've got yourself like your hygiene
covered for the next month like I said
the starter set is just five dollars and
after that a restock box ships with
regular sized products at a regular
price at whatever pace you feel
comfortable so join the club friends
Dollar Shave Club link is down in the
description dollarshaveclub.com slash
matpat that's dollarshaveclub.com slash
math hat feeling fresh
[Music]